moi j'aime beaucoup le cirque mais ça
m'amuse toujours mal à l'aise de voir
des numéros d'animaux
ça me met très mal à l'aise de voir des
animaux dans les eaux
je préférerais qu'il soit autre chose
quand ailleurs quant à l'argument on va
mettre des gens au chômage excusez moi
mais ça n'a rien à voir
le cirque mais il y avait des spectacles
dans le temps où l'on montrait des
humains de contractants à un moment on a
arrêté parce que la conscience humaine
ne le tolérerai plus basse à dîner jours
un noir enfin l'argument c'est pas de
dire vous comprenez continuons à exhiber
des noirs parce que ça des mains des
sages que ça surtout sur le fait que les
animaux avaient à ce que voudrait pas
bien mais non mais parce que là on est
dans la zone est pas belle
je vous dis pas je la comparaison
simplement qui se passe maintenant
analyser fillion nourrit ses modalités
c'est fini mais il fait face maintenant
c'est les animaux ce qui s'est passé
avec certains humains la conscience
humaine et veut comparer pas me sciences
humaines aval je me veux aussi parce
qu'à un moment c'était toléré par
beaucoup de vent mais pas qu'au rayon la
supprimait japonais c'est l'évolution
responsabilités
alors je vous aime beaucoup avec mes
votre comparaison la production du mois
ses rivaux les ricaneurs de l' esclavage
animal on peut le considérer on a le
droit non là je vais pouvoir sur une
année mais attendez soyons cohérents
ça veut dire quoi on promène plus les
chiens en laisse on ferme les eaux on
ferme tous les parcs animaliers hc on
ouvre toutes les 400 étudiants non mais
soyez cohérent bien
[Applaudissements]
agathe vous êtes contre je suis pour le
cirque
j'adore le cirque mais je suis contre
les animaux sauvages dans les cirques
tout bêtement et je pense que ce qu'éric
a essayé de dire il n'a pas essayé de
comparer deux 2 abomination ou de type
d' esclavage vous que c'est j'ai laissé
de comparer des évolutions et 2p
conscience mais à des moments donnés et
je pense effectivement que même même
vous cyril n'importe qui se retrouve
devant un numéro de cirque avec un
éléphant qui va s'asseoir ou un type qui
va sauter dans un dans un cerceau
flamboyant on n'est pas aussi à l'aise
qu'il ya vingt ans face à un numéro
pareil
moi je sais que ça ça me mettrait
segmentation changé il en train de
s'adapter à la société d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les animaux ils sont nés
chez nous en captivité depuis plusieurs
générations
on prélève plus d'aliments dans la
nature on est donc plus ils sont proches
de l'homme il ya une vraie relation
homme animal qui existe et on essaie de
sensibiliser le public et paris grasset
trop la soirée
quand vous parliez du transport nous on
imagine sa fin le je pense que beaucoup
imaginent ça qu on vous imagine aller de
ville en ville transporter des éléphants
des hippopotames des tigres on imagine
forcément des camions exil eu du tout
expliqué dans des conditions insalubres
sur des heures de route là je vais pour
ça que je voudrais bien que les
téléspecteurs le l'entende parce que
c'est important aujourd'hui à des normes
en france pour transporter les animaux
c'est pareil moi j'ai un certificat de
transport qui est valable sur cinq ans
et ce certificat de transport au delà de
huit heures c'est minimum
je ne doit pas dépasser les 8 heures de
transport nous laisse iront se déplace à
peu près une fois par semaine donc ces
quatre déplacements par mois on ne
déplace pas tous les jours les animaux
dans les camions certains les arrivées
où il y avait ainsi recueilli le sommet
drano qui fait des fois détourné avec
une date par ville donc certains cirque
le fond c'est la réalité et parlant de
la règle et aux réunions qu'on a fait au
moins 90 des cas nos propositions pour
un savon de mangeas parlons demande de
renault avait vite la tigre doit voir
quelle taille de cage 28 go voilà on
dans les cirques pendant ta loge ses
sept mètres carrés voilà sept mètres à
réparer après on a des parcs de détente
d'être heures par jours 4 heures par les
chez moi il reste toute la journée chez
vous mais l'argumentation ces quatre
heures par jour
le territoire d'un tigre c'est 60
kilomètres carrés mais non mais c'est la
réalité